what happens when you get a professional
filmmaker someone who's put out films
all over the world and say look we want
you to shoot this but you could only
shoot it with a smartphone
[Music]
hey everybody what is going on now you
know on this channel from time to time
we like to talk about cameras
videography photography smartphones all
those encapsulating content creation
right
but what happens when you give a
smartphone to a professional filmmaker
someone who's made films that have gone
all over the world and you say look we
want you to shoot this but you can only
shoot it with a smartphone what can come
of it well that's exactly what apple has
done and they've done this for a number
of years with various different iphone
iterations but this year is about the
iphone 13 pro and this film is very
special to many of us who live in
singapore like myself because it's about
the iconic dish chicken rice
who makes the best chicken rice how is
it made
and documented from somebody's eyes who
doesn't live here but who's been here
before this filmmaker you've seen his
work on netflix from chef's table to
jiro dreams of sushi
give it up for david gelp hey david how
are you
i'm well thank you how are you today
i'm great man this is exciting uh this
is very exciting i saw your short film
uh about
something close to a lot of our hearts
here in singapore chicken rice
i mean the food culture here is
absolutely amazing and you've traveled
all over the world i'm sure you know
researching food and diving into
different cultures what was it for you
that stood out with singapore
well i think that the story here that
the part of the story here that i was
really drawn to is is passion
and both from the the hawkers you know
the people in the in the uh markets who
are making this food to the customers
there's a ton of passion and um in
singapore people are very passionate
about food and they're very passionate
about chicken rice as you can see in the
film and so that's like perfect fertile
ground for a dramatic story
definitely now this was this the first
time you were in singapore were you here
prior to that uh we went i went to
singapore once before um we did on my
show street food um we did an episode
based in singapore
so i knew about the place a little bit
but i really love it and i had such a
fun time shooting this
okay so getting into chicken rice what's
your take on it what's your uh do you
have a favorite after testing both of
these out
well you know it's tough you know we
have great sauce we have beautiful rice
um you know one is a little fattier on
the other side and then there's a bit
kind of like a leanerness that's going
on uh with uh tienten but i think
they're both fantastic and so you know
as we say in the film you know we leave
it to the audience um to decide but the
incredible thing about chicken rice and
singapore is that there are so many
different takes on something that is
fundamentally similar that everybody can
find their favorite and you know
yeah
it is very cool it's something that we
do uh discuss a lot here we talk at
lunch what we're gonna have for dinner
and what's the favorite place to go for
dinner then we do it at dinner talk
about breakfast and lunch it's just a
a circle of life when it comes to food
very interesting uh culture let's talk a
little about why this story about these
two hawkers that what was it that sort
of drew you into this
well i think again it's their it's the
passion
and it's about what it means to them
personally you know uh mr wong loves
what he does and he does it in his very
specific way and then you have miss loy
who is trying to build this into a
business and expand the reach of what
she's doing and so you have kind of an
old-school way of doing things meeting
kind of like someone who's pushing into
the future and so i think that that's a
really interesting kind of fertile
ground as i said before of like
you know there's drama there is um it's
kind of like a microcosm of a lot of
like conflicts that are generational
conflicts that happen within restaurant
families and uh so we just thought that
this would be a lot of fun to make and
something that would be exciting you
know and also with beautiful food
of course and you know speaking of like
generations and just old style i gotta
look at this backdrop here that you're
in
and it's absolutely beautiful this is
the uh new apple tower theater in
california the apple tower theater in
downtown los angeles um restored into
its um former glory i mean it's got to
be the best video chat background
ever i think and i mean i was like oh
does this look like a green screen like
dude are people gonna believe that this
is real back here it's totally nuts i
love it it's absolutely amazing apple
should make this and put it onto every
mac that they sell as a backdrop for
chats for sure it's beautiful
all right let's get down and let's talk
about the tools of your trade now
can you walk me through a little bit
when you're normally shooting these
documentaries what do you shoot with
usually
well you know typically we use a large
camera system um that requires a sizable
crew
you know starting from jira dreams of
sushi you know a big breakthrough in the
uh tech camera world was when you were
able to shoot things that look like it's
shot on 35 millimeter film
but in fact is digital um you know i i
shot jiro on a red one camera it was a
big breakthrough at the time uh back in
2010
but it was a big step forward because
you could shoot you could make it look
like a film you didn't need to have all
the camera assistance and everything and
you could do slow motion and these were
things that um you know i was drooling
over as a you know i was a film student
before i was a filmmaker and like i
wanted to make things that really look
like movies so that was a huge leap
forward and so now i feel like here's
another leap forward with the iphone um
with iphone you have like these
incredible tools that
you know are comparable to what you use
in a large format system um with a lot
of advantages which i thought was really
kind of an interesting challenge yeah it
is i mean because looking at your past
work and then obviously seeing this uh
film it's really interesting how you've
used the iphone and really maximized its
features and let's talk a little bit
about that what was your first initial
impression because i mean obviously we
carry a phone day in and day out we use
it for instagram we use it for social
media we use it to you know communicate
with families but when you're
sort of brought into this and saying you
need to shoot this on an iphone or can
you shoot this on the iphone
did you have reservations were you
scared were you like i don't know if i
can do this well yeah i mean because you
know i'm used to having you know a much
uh different kind of toolkit but then
iphone 13
um there are certain features that were
just like okay this is what is going to
make this possible to still shoot in my
style using this tool so when i'm using
a big camera i love shooting on very
shallow depth of field with cinema
lenses so when i found out about
cinematic mode and how i can choose
focus i can create a shallow depth of
field
and then go taking it a step further now
i'm able to and this is something i
could only do on iphone i can change
that depth of field
in post
so whether i'm doing it on camera i can
i can tap and like let it rack focus the
way i want it but then i can adjust that
timing and post and that's something
that's just never been done before so
that's like a big plus for me i love
shooting with shallow depth of field i
love focusing in on like the most
beautiful part of my frame and then
letting the back kind of fall off out of
focus and have that beautiful bokeh in
the background
so that was like a major major plus then
uh low lighting capability i was like
this is a camera that cause you know
with the big cameras and these prime
lenses sometimes you lose quite a bit of
light in this case i'm able to shoot
in you know very varied lighting
situations
low light and it records beautifully and
i think those were like two of like the
major
factors now finally macro mode is a big
part of what i do i'm always shooting on
macro lenses shooting close-ups of food
and so this tool on iphone actually was
quite useful and we were able to really
get in there and uh get closer to the
food in perfect focus in a way that i
wasn't able to do uh with a previous
iphone so it's exciting yeah you know
it's interesting when i was watching it
because obviously you know depth of
field is a big factor and that's always
one of the things with smartphones is
it's always been this feature that you
just could tell when something was shot
on a smartphone versus a regular camera
and i was using and like how you
implemented cinematic mode was
interesting because i didn't know
i thought at times you were
i thought maybe you were using you know
manual focus or racking focus or maybe
using a different app to sort of get
that field or maybe another lens you
know there's third-party lenses out
there to adapt but you didn't do any of
that right it was just basically
cinematic mode well yeah i mean and that
was something that i wanted to do
because you know there are there is a
huge aftermarket for lots of uh uh
accessories that can go on on iphone but
i really wanted to show
i really wanted to like push the device
itself
to its limits so the vast majority of
the piece is shot in cinematic mode in
the native app
um and it performed brilliantly and we
found ourselves like being like i just
want to shoot it on cinematic but i want
to shoot everything on cinematic i'm
like obsessed with cinematic mode and uh
you know that's what i've been looking
for for a long time in in in a device so
you have this kind of size of the thing
and then the other crazy thing is just
the ability to and i don't know if you
saw the behind the scenes that we did
but you can see how we attach the camera
to like butcher knives we're hiding
cameras all over the kitchen you can
kind of get this like intimate these
kind of like intimate behind the scenes
moments without them even noticing that
the camera is there so that's a very
very cool feature of the size of the
device as well yeah i want to talk a
little bit about that too because i know
when you know sometimes they say size
matters and when it comes to cameras you
know especially when you're shooting
with clients when they see you coming
with a big rig they feel like their
money's being well spent
but there's the also other side of it
which i personally experience and maybe
you can attest to this or not is that it
can be very intimidating to people that
aren't used to being in front of the
camera when they have a massive camera
set up and lights and all these people
around
so did you notice a more of a comfort
level with your you know with the
participants in the film when you're
shooting with an iphone versus let's say
a red for example oh absolutely i mean i
think that makes a huge difference when
you're filming people who are not used
to being filmed you know because they
have a device too it's not like some
alien thing like they know what an
iphone is you know there's nothing
scary or crazy about it um it doesn't
feel like there's like this kind of
single large eye like staring at you
so it creates a sense of intimacy and
kind of casualness um
but with iphone 13 it actually does look
like a movie so it's pretty it's pretty
awesome thoughts about the process when
they read it again well we wanted to
keep our process like and this was part
of like the challenge that i kind of put
you know that that was kind of posed to
us and that we that we challenged
ourselves with was let's do our normal
shooting workflow
with iphone let's take iphone and take
it to the professional level you know
we're very proud of our show chefs table
that has always been we're one of the
first shows in 4k hdr like you know it's
it's something that we've always taken
pride in in our work is pushing the
technical uh the technical to its limits
um
in this case we were like let's just
take iphone and put it through our
normal workflow process and um it was
really quite fine i mean i don't think
that our editor really like noticed that
much different except for now we have
the ability to change depth of field in
post-production which is another like
it's one more thing that opens up some
possibilities for us which we thought
was interesting i we use our chef's
table colorist and everything turned out
great and you can see it in the skin
tones that you know it looks quite
natural and it for me when i watch it
i'm not really thinking about the format
so much i'm just watching a story and
that's what i hope that our audience
gets from it because i actually was i
didn't even know when you shot cinematic
mode or not i had no idea if you used
another app i was just
it just was seamless and it was really
beautiful to see that come into play
especially with um
people always think that there's this
hindrance with smartphones but i think
this is a testament that you can
actually push the boundaries but i do
want to talk to you a little bit about
sound because sound is a big factor in
this film
and how do i mean obviously you're not
using the internal mics on the on the
phone right in this case well we would
run the internal mic in case you could
capture something that's in a proximity
sometimes we're just shooting on the fly
and we're capturing some sound through
the internal mics which we were
surprised at how well they were working
but for interviews things like that
again not to break the feeling of what
we're normally doing we do have a sound
recordist and we're using external mics
but it's syncing up very easily with the
sound so i'm basically taking my chef's
table crew
and shooting on iphone and just like
being like how does this camera work for
us and uh
in in the case of sound it was quite
easy to just sync up the sound uh
afterwards you know but there often was
usual usable sound ambient sound that we
took off of the iphone itself that
worked fine any last words for
filmmakers that you would give or a
device that you would give out there
that want to do something like this that
maybe you're thinking they need to buy
all this expensive gear
anything for them well i mean absolutely
i mean i wish that i had this when i was
making jira drinks with sushi because it
would have made my life like so much
easier and i would have an incredible
beauty in in in my shock quality
um this film was made really
i didn't put any cages there are maybe
occasionally i'll use an nd filter in a
very very bright environment just like
bring the overall
brightness down or something like that
but really
this is a naked phone shooting these
shots um we're attaching it to things
it's really the main kind of accessories
that we're using so you know what i
think is that it kind of like
democratizes filmmaking in a way
you know if you're able to get your
hands on on the device and to be honest
the entire it doesn't even have to be a
pro like the entire iphone series i
think has a number of these capabilities
you know you can make a movie from soup
to nuts
it makes you have to worry about the
financing and the money and like all
those extra tools less and focus more on
the story and on the character so if you
have a device like this if you have
iphone and you have a great story to
tell you find a great character that's
really all that you need and i think
that's really exciting and i think it
opens up the field because these tools
like slow motion low light cinematic
mode um a macro
uh it's all available now at a much
lower you know price point that i think
opens up the field to a lot of young
filmmakers so i'm like really excited to
see what they come up with one last one
for you okay you've done this apple's
obviously very happy they've worked with
you before
if they had if they asked you they said
david what's one thing you would love to
see
in another iphone what's one feature for
filmmakers what would that feature be
well i think that pushing forward
i love this direction of cinematic mode
and i just want to see and i expect this
to happen as iphone 14 15 you know as
the future unfolds that you'll have more
shooting capability you'll have more
options within this mode um which i
think is really exciting so to be able
to shoot cinematic mode even larger
format
being able to shoot cinematic mode in
slow motion and this is what i expect
that the future iphones will will will
bring to us so i'm so excited about the
future as well
all right david thank you so much once
again uh and we hope that you come back
to singapore now that flights are
available we can travel again i know
singapore air has been emailing me
they're like come here
come on back and i'm like i'm tempted
i'm tempted all right david thank you
once again really appreciate it
congratulations on the film and guys
that's it david gelb
on this awesome chicken rice wars
here's shot on the iphone 13 pro david
thanks and take care we'll talk to you
soon thank you so much appreciate you
oh man that's it that's fun man that is
awesome i love it love it learning about
filmmaking from somebody who does this
on a much bigger scale but just using
the iphone 13 pro how cool is that all
right if you guys like this video hit
that like button smash that subscribe
button as well stay safe out there and
we will chat to you soon take care
you